I'm worried about funny I'm 25 years old
I race cars this one I do a September 15
2006 I forget when I buy signal what you
see here is a little bit of
improvisation we basically electrical
tape my hands to what I usually normally
drive with the daily drivers we gonna do
competition stuff to make sure my hands
don't lose control over what the whole
car is dude
I can't wait to get to turn ten just to
talk with the guys to just meet the
engineers and talking to the actual
designers of the game and seeing what
actually goes into making a video game
meeting Mario and understanding his
story that's exactly why we do forts
bring people together around cars bring
people together with their friends get
people talking about cars before the
motorsport game currently you're
somewhat limited to just a racing scene
in a racing track the environment so the
fact that Forza horizon 2 allows you to
go and leave the racetrack going pretty
much explore the world it's pretty cool
the idea is that you're on this epic
road trip in southern Europe you're
travelling to the festival when you're
involved in all these race events
throughout this beautiful southern
European landscape it's got over 200
cars and it's got this huge land mass
that you can explore so you can be on a
mountainside at the top of san giovanni
and look across and see like a bell
tower and sister on and it just kind of
blows your mind because it is miles and
miles and miles away
at all times when you're driving a car
and what's the horizon - it should feel
like the real thing it should feel like
a forts again so you'll be able to tune
the cars exactly how you want them
for the first time in a Forte's a game
you're gonna see whether it's always
changing day turned to night night
turned today watching the clouds roll in
rain fuel on around seeing a car kind of
glitter with the little bits of you know
water beating up on it it's just
beautiful
the Xbox one we're able to build that
social network that social cohesion
between players and really bring it to
life in Forza horizon 2 so the idea of
going on our road trip in southern
Europe with your friends is immediately
attractive but when you combine all the
different types of events that the game
has everything balloon hill climbs to
cross country events to point Winx
friends and showcase races where you're
racing things like steam trains and
aerial stunt shows uses this sort of
fantasy that could only come to life in
a video game so what's her horizon
covers your bases with great music and
exploration but it's more forgiving it's
more easy to drift around and have fun
knowing that Mario drives competitively
really has made his ability to go fast
you know at the heart of of his mission
and I love the force can open up that
world to him even more or help him in
any way that's
obviously we love cars but getting the
real passion that's what that's our fuel
that keeps us going
plus I think my should be filled on his
passion and that's what I live off of so
it's perfect